do you have what it takes
you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it it's coming
I can't do this without you
no matter what you choose
we'll come out bloody
welcome back everyone it's Charlie there
was just a big comic-con panel in London
earlier today where they showed off a
bunch of new Witcher footage so I'll
break that down really good news too we
also have a much better lock on what the
actual release date for the series is
going to be so if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Witcher videos I'll be doing episode
videos and Easter eggs when it gets here
we'll find some cool which are a themed
giveaway to do for a merch or something
for The Witcher episode videos that I'll
do so at London MCM comic-con they
screened a couple new Witcher clips that
they have not released publicly yet so
the first clip shows yennefer eulogizing
a baby we know she'll try to save
the baby and her mother a queen Kaless
of larrya that she's been traveling with
that's what this scene from the last
trailer is for with all these
bodies in the circle around this wagon
they've been traveling in a wagon
together they get attacked by an unknown
mage we see them teleport across a bunch
of different destinations but yennefer
is unsuccessful in evading the sorcerer
it's actually what this fight is here
with her in this desert looking
background behind her she's fighting the
mage that's coming for Queen Kahless and
her baby all of universe efforts are in
vain is both Queen Kayla and her baby
don't survive the encounter then in the
sky a bird starts circling around the
two of them the two sorcerers as they're
having their gunslingers standoff moment
in the scene cuts to yennefer sitting at
a beach wearing her black outfit with
her hair all messed up from the fight as
the camera cuts to the actual baby
itself she looks up at the bird and says
which one of us are you here for she
starts speaking to the baby and says I'm
sorry you didn't have a life but truth
be told you're not missing much
the camera cuts back to yennefer I know
it's easy for me to say with warm breath
in my lungs and you with nothing still
what would you have had parents well
they're the ones who wrote your last act
so not much lost their friends most
likely Fairweather lovers fun for a bit
I'll admit but will eventually
disappoint if you haven't played the
games or read the books I'll explain why
yennefer seems so pessimistic about life
itself some music starts softly playing
and then she goes on to say and let's
face it you're a girl your mother was
right about one thing were just vessels
and even when we're told we're special
as I was as you would have been we're
still just vessels
for them to take in take until we're
empty and alone so count yourself lucky
you cheated the game and won without
even knowing it sleep well the music
swells up and then she starts to bury
the baby in the scene cuts out to
another scene completely different scene
of serie meeting a character named ara
who is not a book character this scene
comes before Siri winds up with the
dryads in Brokilon after she's trying
to escape Cintra so the timeline of the
books is going to be a little bit different
from the timeline of the show because
they condensed a bunch of stuff the way
the fray Alan described this character
at the comic-con panel because he's not
an original book characters that he's
this main source for her different
perspective and viewpoint and vital to
keeping her going early on they make a
good team but they're from completely
different backgrounds and it just meant
to sort of get her ready for her
encounter with Geralt because they're
also kind of at odds when they first run
into each other until Geralt realizes
how important she is so they using it as
a way to introduce non book readers to
Siri because you learn a lot more about
her character during these scenes what
her personality is like before you get
all the Geralt scenes so that when
they're together and when she's with the
dryads you don't just spend all this
extra time explaining who her character
is but it picks up with ciri in the
snowy forest scene here we actually seen
shots of this that they've released
recently she's looking all battered with
visible scratches on her face dirty hair
the music's playing behind her she
approaches a bush of berries holding out
a hand to pick one something gets thrown
at her hand and she picks up a stick in
gaps who's there then the dark character
appears from behind a tree he's wearing
a coat in a hat stop right there he says
he motions for her not to eat the
berries
she says you mean they're poison then
Dora signals for her to follow and we
see a rat
ciri is still holding the stick she says
oh no thank you
I don't eat rat Dara shrugs as if to
leave she says wait don't go the scene
cuts to a shot of a fire with a roasted
wrath and Dora eating it ciri asks him
where in Cintra did you live where are
your parents why don't you talk I
haven't spoken to anyone in three days
guess we're all on the run I'm supposed
to be going towards someone but instead
I'm running from someone else he has
this this big bird on his head I don't
even know what he wants from me we
should smother the fire I can't be
caught by him I can't Daraa offers her
what's left of the rat ciri accepts cut
to
wandering through the woods they're
freezing Siri gives Dora one of her
gloves then sees a flag she says look
it's a Centron flag come on were saved
then series starts running towards the
flag when she turns to check on Dora the
boy is gone completely
she asks rat-boy where did you go then
we cut to a shot of the next scene right
after this of jet-skier singing this
whole scene of siri trying to escape
something she talks about two men that
she's trying to get away from is
probably from sword of Destiny when
she's actually trying to escape an
arranged marriage she takes off out of
Cintra and winds up in the forest
of brokilin where the dryads live and that's how she winds up running into Geralt for the
first time all this footage of her
talking to the dryads here that's from
that moment there where she's forced to
choose between a life with Geralt or
life with the dryads because the Dryas
want her for her secret power too
because she has the elder blood they
recognize how special she is this is
also around the time where Gayle
realizes that she's the child of
surprise of Dooney in pavetta her two
parents do nee actually shows up in the
trailer he's the one with the head that
looks kind of like a hedgehog and all
these big fight scenes in the throne
room in Cintra so these might be in
flashbacks is not really clear how
they're going to deal with flashbacks or
how linear the story is going to be told
because a lot of the material from the
last wish in sort of destiny the first
two books of short stories that season
one is going to borrow from take place
in a bunch of different times that they
jump around in time as Geralt is
remembering these events also really
cool at the convention they had this
installation with one of the monsters
that shows up during the trailer we got
a little more information about it it's
actually a key Kimura which is from the
game itself it's basically a giant
spider with a human-like looking head
they each I have this social structure
amongst them you find a lot of them in
the swamps which is why you see Geralt
fighting one in a swamp during the
trailer the scene of yennefer also kind
of tees up the idea that she and Geralt
eventually become the mother and father
figures to ciri she eventually gives all
of her motherly love to ciri once
they're all together part of yennefer
sacrifice in becoming a sorceress
attaining that power is becoming barren
but also Geralt in taking all of his
witcher potions becoming a witcher
originally made him barren too so
neither one of them can actually have
children themselves so serious order
their adoptive child we also haven't
gotten any scenes of yennefer actually
meeting Geralt for the first time but
they
did say that they would sort of come
together on parallel storylines by the
end of the first season that's the story
of the last wish it actually involves a
genie of all things you have to imagine
that there's all kinds of different
magical creatures in the world of The
Witcher books dandelion and Geralt are
fishing dandelion pulls a jar out of the
stream realizes there's a genie in it
and unwittingly releases it
the genie attacks him Geralt goes to the
nearest town to get help for him and
yennefer just happens to be there she
agrees to help them but decides that she
wants the genies wish for herself while
she's busy fighting the genie trying to
contain him the town starts being
destroyed Geralt realizes the genies too
powerful for her goes to help her and
tries to persuade her to let it go
because she wants his wish so badly but
then Geralt realizes that he's holding
the jar to seal the genie and knows that
he's the one really controlling him so
he uses his final wish to save yennefer
and bind their fates together forever
so the title of the book in the short
story the last wish is the story of how
their fates became intertwined he uses
the genies last wish to save her since
we haven't seen the episodes yet we
don't know exactly how faithful these
moments are going to be to the book
moments but the showrunner did say that
they sort of rearranged a couple things
to make the story a little more linear
and easier to follow because like I said
most of these early short stories just
jump around all over the place in time
and aren't really that connected as for
the actual release date there was a
contest at MCM comic-con in a banner
that seemingly confirmed the leak from
earlier this year earlier this year the
Netflix Netherlands Twitter account
accidentally posted the release date of
a bunch of different titles in December
it listed The Witcher was coming out the
week of December 17th the week right
before Christmas but then Netflix came
out and said no no this isn't accurate
months went by without any updates then
just this weekend at London MCM
comic-con there's a banner for a contest
to win tickets to The Witcher premiere
and guess what day it's on so it
seemingly confirms that leak that it's
got to be dropping that week most of the
time Netflix drops episodes on Fridays
but there are some weeks where they'll
drop it on an off day and because this
is so close to the holidays at the end
of the year it seems like that's what
they're going to do so I will be doing
bonus videos there's going to be another
really big trailer that they'll drop
next weekend so of course I'll do a
video for that too
but if you have any big questions or
bonus videos for The Witcher series that
you want me to do just let me know in
the comments everyone click here for my
Easter eggs from that last big Witcher
trailer and click here for all my Easter
eggs from the new star wars episode 9
rise of the Skywalker trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight